[Musik]
hallo
heute gibt es eine ganz einfache torte
und war die rotkäppchen fort
die roten sind orte heißt so weil sie
auf der oberfläche rot ist und die kenne
ich aus meiner kindheit schon meine
cousine hat die immer zu unserem
geburtstag in zubereitet jedenfalls ist
es im prinzip hier unten ganz normaler
einfache zeit mit vanille und schoko
keine quark sahne creme und hier schon
viel chemie obendrauf bis hin zum
classic ja wirklich vom fertigen ganz
einfach ja so ungefähr was immer mal
fragen der moral und darauf achtet auf
eine große rolle
dadurch konnte gleich besser für den
rührteig traurig 175
preisgeber war mayer etwas anliegt und
eine prise mit kamel zwei teelöffel
backpulver 20 gramm kakaopulver 40
milliliter lauwarme milch und ein glas
schatten modell die habe ich jetzt
bereits abgetropft um den platz
aufgefangen
der verein nehme ich jetzt die
futterumstellung an den ganz normalen
einfachen rührteig her und da ist ebenso
wichtig dass die zutaten alles immer
warm sind
und falls jemand vergessen uns die
butter vor herauszustellen können sie
einfach fein reiben mit meiner küchen
reibe und ganze schneller
da kommt jetzt noch locker mit der man
den extrakt umsatz und dann wird die
mischung in etwa drei bis vier minuten
cremig gerührt
wenn die mutter mache dann zudem weiß
frau mit jetzt kommen die eier
nacheinander
wir werden jeweils eine halbe minute
eingebüßt
[Musik]
jetzt müsste ich mir mit und viele die
zutaten in den tag hinein
cacau vom toni kroos wenn ich habe
seinen hellen teig und dann gleich noch
im dunklen
das wäre ich jetzt ganz kurz ein
und die hälfte des tages fünf vierteln
eine vorbereitete backform habe ich hier
bereits einen backing off 26 cm
durchmesser eingestellt zum restlichen
teig gebe ich jetzt kakaopulver und
millimeter so und für die zutaten club
ein und den dunkel zeigt wahrscheinlich
dann auf dem hellen
[Musik]
die kirchen verteidigen muss gleichmäßig
über dem teich und rückte dann nur ganz
leicht rein
[Musik]
und bei kuchen mit dem vorgreifen
backofen bei 160 grad ober unterhitze
etwa 35 minuten gewann
der kuchen ist bereits abgekühlt
hinten steht momentan ich habe ihn auch
für eine halbe stunde im kühlschrank und
nicht weil ich die creme zu bereiten die
rotkäppchen vorder besteht aus 53 und
dann eine qual ich und oben eine kirsche
ich sage ich mal die zutaten für die
creme auf 400 milliliter schlagsahne
etwas länger part 5 105 watt eine
umarmten sich ohne computer von elektro
und für den gut 250 millimeter
wir schlafen letzten super und weise
verschönern norwegen gut vorstellen in
den därmen bisschen abkühlen das heißt
ich gebe den kirschbaum in einem kleinen
topf kommen
zucker und stärke dazu dass ganz ruhiges
kind frei und lass es einmal aufkochen
[Musik]
jetzt darf der kurs etwas abkühlt und
ich nehme inzwischen schon mal die sonne
die kunstwerke fertig machen schiene
aber mit dem handrührgerät natürlich
auch und werde ich hier jetzt vier
zähler für seiner fahrt ein römer
benutzt immer einen fehler für pro 100
gramm zusammen das gebe ich auch etwas
von exakt
[Musik]
und wenn die sahne fast ganz scheitern
kommt und bergwerk meter zu erbringen
schönen weiblichen geschmack mit dem die
torte oder zucker 5 teelöffel salz und
ein bisschen zitronenschalen abkriegt
und es könnte noch eingeholt und so
lange gut bis die creme schön fände
[Musik]
als nächste krieg führte vom bug klick
herunter und dann mit einem treffer
wunderbar folie in den tortenring lassen
wird um herum streicht jetzt die creme
drüber wirklich super einfacher kuchen
oder nicht einfach fort und die creme
wird schön zu stricken
[Musik]
und weil ich möchte dass die torte schön
sauber aus lieblings hier diesen
schmutzigen ran denn diesmal einfach mit
dem zweck
[Musik]
und hier verteile ich jetzt gibt er
stelle sich taufen
[Musik]
die verteilt jetzt am besten so in die
torte hochnehmen und einfach und
effizient herstellen
[Musik]
die tore für mindestens zwei stunden
gekühlt und danach können wir gleich
probieren
[Musik]
also lieber auf
finden unter mehrere männer in ihren rot
möglich
nur ein wolf klub ihn jeden tag an
ja ich finde die meisten menschen sind
aber auch sehr angsteinflößend
und ich muss sagen wollte hatte die
meisten menschen so ziemlich künstlich
nachgemacht oder mündlich erzählt aber
die meisten menschen konturierten schon
ziemlich brutal vor allem die passion
der gebrüder grimm wein abgehakt
dafür hat man halt das erzählen heute
brutal
und so lange nägel und alles garantiert
so wenig die rot gibt sind orte sehr
sehr hübsch
1 hit gar keine gabel braucht der wolf
ist nicht wirklich super und super
einfach hoch explosiv
gleich zu verausgaben ja noch die
säurefreien kirschen bis schokolade mit
der perfekte kurven für einen sonntag
für einen geburtstag für eine weil das
ist ein ganz normaler tag und mama guck
mir auch eine richtig dicke romane super
also falls ihr dieses rezept auch nach
machen wollen dann geht auf wenn ich mir
das jetzt noch mal ganz genau
und ja schade mouratidis nicht um wolf
gesehen dürfen aber jetzt auch
rotkäppchen verspeist fangen wir mich
weiter also viel spaß danach machen und
wir sind gut weggekommen
[Musik]
nein